alors jean pierre marielle ça me paraît
un superbe résumé mais vous fait quand
même partie des comédiens qui ne se sont
jamais vraiment éloigné du théâtre
c'était à vous fait une carrière au
cinéma mais bien régulièrement vous
retourner sur les planches du théâtre ça
c'est comme ça moi je suis un acteur de
théâtre qui fait du cédez pas à moi j'ai
commencé avant j'étais avant tout au
départ un acteur théâtre j'ai une
formation complètement classique et pg
fait du cinéma assez tard enfin j'ai
commencé en faisant des petits rôles
mais je reviens toujours au théâtre
quand je trouve une pièce valin quand
j'ai envie de jouer quelque chose s'il
est pas par e.on sentir l'odeur des
coulisses on me suivait parce que tout à
coup il ya une urgence
voilà il y en a une